[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number
177. I'm Dr Brett Weinstein my pronouns
are I and me this is Dr Heather heying
her pronouns are also I and me that's
gonna get confusing because it is
confusing
the way we deal with this in our
household is that when I refer to you I
use be her pronouns whoa I know that
sounds edgy and when you refer to me you
use he him pronouns also edgy that's why
we keep it straight yeah how English and
all the other languages came up with a
solution to this problem a long time ago
a problem that reduces ambiguity yep
um now as I said in our q a last week if
you're wondering about your gender
identity you can just strike that right
off your to-do list because it's not a
thing and you don't need to worry about
it right usually if you're sitting next
to someone reasonable if you're at all
confused you could just ask them they
can tell you
yeah or not but or not yeah right all
right so here we are 177 not prime nope
not Prime 3 by 59.
I totally knew that um
and here we are live streaming on Rumble
and we will do a q a exclusively on
Rumble when we are done here we're going
to move most of our usual preamble to a
post animal this week and jump very
quickly into
um into our sponsors but first just
encourage you if you're watching on
YouTube uh uh to come over to rumble and
watch there subscribe to the channel we
appreciate it and we'll talk more about
all the other places uh that you can
find us at the end of the episode but
for right now we will start with our
sponsors uh who we have whom
we will start with no we will start with
our sponsors whom we appreciate very
very much and we have three of them as
always at the top of the hour here we go
okay our first one our first sponsor
this week is brand new to us it's iherb
that's i-h-e-r-b and yes that is how
it's pronounced even though the word
herb is not pronounced with the uh
audible H I cannot make me pronounce the
h well that's why I'm reading the ad
there it is because they insist
Lord
it's iherb i-h-e-r-b iherb offers the
best curated selection of wellness
products at terrific value across a
variety of categories including
supplements Sports Nutrition Beauty and
baby that's a category
iherb can be and should be your One-Stop
shop for all your health and wellness
needs okay so when they approached us
when I heard approached us my thought
was what makes them different what is
special about yet another online
retailer then I found my own notes from
two years ago when I had set up an
account with iherb and begun ordering
from them I had already answered my own
question I had just forgotten the answer
but I'm going to tell you what the
answer was and remains today
which is that what makes iherb different
is that they really do carefully curate
what they sell and they do it extremely
well
so in the wake of
um pandemic and such we had begun to
look for supplements which is not
something we had ever done before and I
had begun to use consumerlab.com which
does very careful analyzes of
supplements to assess whether they
contain what they say they do and
whether they don't contain things that
you don't want them to but many of their
most highly recommended Brands just
aren't very widely available they're
very hard to find and what I had found a
couple years ago and it is still true
today is that iherb is the exception to
that rule and see if bewildering and
often fallacious claims about what is in
the product you are buying I herb is
selling the best of the best products
that actually are what they claim to be
iherb cares what's inside every bottle
that comprise your morning beauty or
Wellness routine they test and verify to
ensure that what you find in every
bottle is what's supposed to be there on
their site you can search by category
brand or ailments you want help with
like circulatory support or just
digestive support and you can further
narrow your search by ratings price and
dietary restrictions their site is easy
convenient and accurate for a limited
time new customers get 22 off their
entire order of their exclusive offer so
go to iherb.com and use promo code
Darkhorse to get 22 off
in the winter when the sun is scarce and
we're spending more time inside we have
begun taking daily supplements D and C
and zinc and magnesium and sometimes a
few more things like turmeric
we get it all from my herb everything
I've ordered from my herb has been a
snap arrived quickly and I know I'm
getting what I'm paying for I also know
that my products have been taken care of
before they get to me as all iherb
orders are stored and shipped
exclusively by iherb no third-party
Sellers and they ship from
climate-controlled fulfillment centers
they shipped over 185 countries and in
the U.S free shipping kicks in on all
purchases over twenty dollars so it's
time to get your health in check with
iherb our listeners get 22 off your
first order when you use code Darkhorse
iherb.com that's 22 off your first order
at
iherb.com promo code Darkhorse choose
iherb because Wellness matters
so does this plant which I just ran into
our second sponsor this week is American
Hartford gold if you listen to Dark
Horse regularly then you already know
just how incompetent and unstable many
of our institutions are becoming
institution is it's nope inflation is at
its highest level in 40 years I would
say institutions are at their lowest
level in ever ever yes in the
hunter-gatherer of times yes since
before institutions institutions really
suck now inflation is its highest level
in 40 years interest rates are Sky High
we're caught between runaway inflation
and the recession and our leaders are
increasingly nonsensical all this
threatens businesses jobs and retirement
funds your money finding ways to secure
your nest egg and insulate your wealth
is more important than ever and adding
precious metals to your assets is a
great way to stabilize your Investments
and protect yourself financially
American Hartford gold is a precious
metals dealer that can help you do just
that American Hartford gold helps
individuals and families protect their
wealth by diversifying with precious
metals they make it simple and easy to
protect your savings and retirement
accounts with physical gold and silver
with one short phone call they can have
physical gold and silver delivered right
to your door or inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients and if you call them
right now they will give you up to five
thousand dollars of free silver on your
first qualifying order
contact American Hartford gold today by
visiting the link in the episode
description below or call
866-828-1117 that's 866
start again that's 866 828 1117 or text
Darkhorse to
998899 once more that's to reach
American Hartford gold
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
and the dog is snoring the dog is
snoring the dog is not interested in
precious metals because we've got that
taken care of before yes they are not
tasty
um yes I I for some reason fear I'm
about to have a flare-up of Dyslexia we
will see if I can get through this ad
before that happens
our final sponsor this week is MD
hearing aid MD hearing aid makes high
quality simple and effective hearing
aids for a tiny fraction of what most
hearing aids cost helping bring audio
Clarity and capacity to people who might
not otherwise be able to afford it while
we don't have need for hearing aids we
have a friend who does and we asked her
to assess MD hearing aids newest product
carefully and honestly she did and her
latest testimonial is at the end of this
ad
MD hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop quality hearing aids that anyone
could afford he kept the price Low by
simplifying the product removing several
rarely needed components and he made a
product that aims to fit so well no one
will know you're wearing it other
features include rechargeable batteries
that last up to 30 hours water
resistance and up to three feet of water
and their volt plus water in their volt
plus model see there it was
but it's back under control not too bad
so far you do not need a prescription to
get one MD hearing aid has cut out the
middleman so you buy your hearing aid
directly from the source where
audiologists and licensed hearing
Specialists are available seven days a
week
here's the newest testimonial from our
friend who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product product and
here's what she said quote I tested the
Neo Neo the new in-ear Canal hearing
aids offered by MD hearing aid I was a
bit skeptical since I'd never liked the
in-ear Canal models preferring the
stability of the over-the-ear sets they
were surprisingly comfortable and stable
staying put without coming loose even
when I wore them to exercise I tried the
Neo in several situations
from Discord voice chat to an in-person
conversation in a room with a white
noise generator and they passed every
test it is true they don't have the
individual audio programming and
smartphone integration of my usual
hearing aids but they have everything
else for less than five percent the
price they provided an absolutely
stunning level of quality for pennies on
the dollar MD hearing aid this is after
that quote MD hearing aid is bringing
affordable hearing to hundreds of
thousands of people who might not
otherwise be able to afford high quality
hearing aids so
if you want MD hearing aids smallest
hearing aid yet go to mdhearingaid.com
and use the promo code Darkhorse to get
their new buy one get one deal a pair of
hearing aids cost just 149.99 plus
Darkhorse listeners receive a free extra
charging case which is a hundred dollar
value
so head to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids for only
149.99
all right so um
let's Jump Right In we have a number of
things to talk about today and uh for
the first section I want to return to a
topic that we spent some time on last
week the the topic that we ended on last
week which was that I had um and I will
try to find the camera this time I had
talked extensively about this book where
there is no doctor a Village Healthcare
handbook this is our copy from this is a
second printing of the second edition so
this it happens to be from 1994 but it's
a 1992 edition of this book which was
originally published in Spanish in the
70s and the first edition in English was
in the 70s and I talked a fair bit about
what um
what an extraordinary resource this is
uh I had it with me at least on one of
my extended field seasons in Madagascar
where there in fact was no doctor and uh
it is you know it provides it provides
Insight information and an ability to
quickly generate skills plus an ability
to know sort of what should be in your
medical kit what drugs should you have
on hand if you're going to be in remote
places or if you are specifically
um in a remote Village
um either living there because that is
where you live or trying to do health
care or other kind of social work with
people who have lived there all of their
lives and one of the things I said last
week was it turns out there's a new
edition published in 2022 I do not know
how it has changed well that new edition
has since arrived this is the 22
2022 Edition these look very very
similar right one of them is clearly
rather well more loved you can't maybe
tell that on the camera here but it's
been through well it's been to
Madagascar and back in other places and
through many moves and this is this 2022
Edition is a brand new brand new book
so I did not compare every single thing
in both of these books of course but
they did make it easy to compare because
the pagination is the same between the
two editions and the table of contents
are mostly the same
and so I was able to kind of you know go
in and spot check various things and I
want to report out on what on what I
find because I think this is a
relatively rare opportunity to directly
compare
uh two two books uh uh um a text that we
relied on 30 years ago 31 years ago
which has come out with a new edition in
a field that is to say medicine uh that
has of course changed rather
dramatically
um or at least very obviously uh at
least in the last few years and so I've
got some some categories of things to
say and you can interrupt anytime
because there's a sort of
um it goes on and on and on and you know
at some point it'll stop but um I
basically I want to talk about some good
things that have not changed at all
between the two editions I'm going to
talk about the rare mistake from the
earlier Edition that I found that's not
corrected in the modern one some changes
that are suggestive of what I call
creeping stupidity in the medical field
and then I want to talk about how their
recommendations on vaccinations have
changed finally and that's the longest
part of the discussion because as far as
I find it's actually the the place in
the book that has changed the most which
is what I was concerned about when I was
talking about the 1992 Edition last week
and it turns out that those concerns
were were warranted okay so first
some good things that have not changed
at all that are identical between the
two editions and and this will give you
a sense an even greater sense than the
conversation we had last week of what's
what kind of things are in this book
um
in 1992 where there is no doctor
recommended that babies be exclusively
breastfed for the first six for the
first four months of the life
and in 2022 they've actually increased
that and recommend that babies be
exclusively breastfed for six months the
first six months of life and uh and then
there are uh that comes up multiple
times throughout the book and in each
case uh both editions are very firm on
the idea that you know breast is best
now this is you know the the 2022
Edition may have coexisted with this um
cryptically dangerous fed is best
Paradigm that we've talked about uh on
Dark Horse before but breast is best is
still but they're going with and that
makes the best sense for mothers for
babies for for people
um in both editions they say and there's
relatively staunch about this they say
for most medicines no medicine I'm sorry
for most sicknesses no medicine is
needed great they want they want you to
use your own body drink drink a lot of
water eat good food have a clean latrine
that is maintained uh get good sleep get
good exercise and that is the way to
health to maintaining health and that is
those are also the things that you
should use to get back to health
um
they say in the healing without
medicines chapter people will get well
for most sicknesses including the common
cold and flu by themselves without need
for medicines and they say even in a
case of more serious illness when a
medicine may be needed it is the body
that most overcome the disease the
medicine only helps cleanliness rest
nutritious food and lots of water are
still very important so again this is
this is consistent between the two
and it is
perfectly consistent with evolutionary
Logic the body is designed to stabilize
itself and when it has become
unstabilized there are many mechanisms
that will cause it to return exactly to
health and so you know the lesson for
frankly
uh civilization
ought to be do what you can to disrupt
those normal processes that are so well
built and so difficult to understand
because taking a process and disrupting
it and then correcting for the
disruption is always harder than just
simply not disrupting right maintain
homeostasis when you can
uh get ahead of processes that could
become positive feedback processes
runaway processes that will send more
and more of your systems more and more
out of out of sync and out of Health
which then may require medicines and
then the medicines may require more
medicines to deal with the side effects
of the first etc etc okay yeah I was
also just going to say that the
extrapolation from that and I don't
think the book is going to deal as much
with that but the obvious extrapolation
is that we ought to treat
um the developmental period with
spectacular care disrupted minimally
well and I you know they don't use that
language but there is a lot in in this
book and and there is a companion book
which we don't have
um specifically for
um women around childbirth and such
but there was a lot in here about the
different ways that we should be
treating children and pregnant women and
and and newborns uh which is suggestive
of that being understood without it
being explicit that the earlier in
development you are the more fragile you
are the more easily disrupted systems
are and the less likely if you disrupt
them early you are to have healthy
systems later on and I would just
um add to this I know you have lots of
places to go but that in some sense
although a developmental environment
could be upgraded and it could be made
to fit better with the adult environment
that the person is developing to live in
you are far better with a developmental
environment that is coherent and worked
from 500 years ago than you are from
some novel combination of things that
have not yet passed the test of time
that's right so you know an Amish
childhood would not leave a child
perfectly well adjusted for the modern
world but it would certainly not mess
them up in the same way that we seem to
be doing across the board by giving them
dozens of new inputs which can't their
effect can't be tracked because it's too
noisy when you have that much complexity
right oh you know my child my child is
is suffering
well
um you started off with formula and they
were sleeping on a mattress that was
off-gassing all sorts of things the
child never should have been breathing
you've been kept inside the child's been
kept inside out of the Sun out of some
misguided attempt to um to protect him
from skin cancer when what he needed was
sun he doesn't move his body pieces in
front of a screen all the time once he
was off formula he is drinking Coke and
eating Fritos uh you know it on and on
and on goes like how do you separate how
do you point to any one of those as the
culprit even though I think everything
that I just named is actually now
completely understood to be contributing
to some of the health problems that so
many of us are experiencing yeah and
that's a tiny part fraction of the list
on top of that parents are being
instructed to override the natural
impulse that would exist for
evolutionary reasons to correct their
child's wrong thinking they are now
being induced to reinforce a child's uh
incorrect thinking about for example
their own sex and
um there is no telling what happens you
know should we expect more of this in
the future of course you should because
you're putting bad data into the
people's heads you know instead of
saying no honey you're not a girl right
we are say oh geez are you you know I
had no idea the obstetrician told me
exactly the opposite and
um anyway that uh informational chaos is
that's outside the purview of the book
right this this book is not primarily
about
um parenting outside of distinctly
medical
um medical cases although obviously what
you're talking about has has has
steamrolled into medical space but a few
more things between the two editions
that uh that aren't changed and that are
quite terrific I read last week from
chapter six the right and wrong uses of
modern medicines
um with you know things like there is
some danger in the use of any medicine
to be helpful medicine must be used
correctly all of this is unchanged
between the two editions
in chapter nine I also read instructions
and precautions for injections including
it is more dangerous to inject medicine
than to take it by mouth also unchanged
between the two additions and there is
for instance I'm not going to show it
it's a it's a little graphic but there's
a flowchart of how to care for a person
with acute diarrhea and um that sounds
like something you don't want to think
about well you don't want to think about
it until it's right in front of you
right it's clear it's easy to interpret
it's identical in both editions they're
not changing things you know there's a
whole lot between these two additions
that are in fact the same which is
terrific
well in fact I would just point out that
obviously a book that is based on the
idea of what you should do in the
absence of the latest medical technology
and and uh
the institutions that deliver it should
change very slowly
yes well as we shall see some of the
things that should not have changed
changed rather dramatically
so
um I found I think it's just one really
the what I'm calling the rare mistake
from the earlier Edition that's not
corrected in 2022. uh so if you would
show uh the first picture now Zach this
is from page 110 uh in which they're
talking about how to make sure that your
child is well nourished add high energy
helper Foods this be this section begins
by saying you know most most cultures
have a dominant basically starch you
know it's going to be potato or quinoa
or cassava or Maniac it's going to be
some rice that
um that is the main thing but that very
often that's not going to be enough they
argue and so they say add high energy
helper foods such as oils and sugar or
honey to the main food it is best to add
vegetable oil or foods containing oils
nuts ground nuts peanuts or seeds
especially pumpkin or sesame seeds and
on the bottom right of this image that
I'm showing you here and this is just a
picture I took from I don't remember
which one of these it was but it's
identical in the two editions if your
child's belly fills up before her energy
needs are met the child will become thin
and weak to meet her energy needs a
child would need to eat this much boiled
rice and there's a big pile on on the
leaf in front of her
but she needs only this much rice when
some vegetable oil is mixed in
well it's possible that the way that
vegetable oils were being made in 1992
weren't quite the same as how they're
being made now but uh in general
vegetable oil sounds like a healthy
alternative to you know things like
butter and and lard and it's quite the
opposite so especially now and I suspect
even back 30 years ago but for sure now
almost all of the oils that you will get
and that are used in basically you know
any time that you aren't in control of
the oil you're using are seed oils and
they are being created through processes
that leave so much toxicity in the oils
themselves this is the opposite of a
healthy food you should not be adding
vegetable oil to your child's rice to
increase the nutritional content that's
a terrible idea lard may be coconut oil
ghee butter any number of animal animal
fats or you know something like olive
oil or avocado oil or coconut oil but um
you know the stuff that's passing for
vegetable oil safflower sunflower canola
grape seed not not good at all and
that's just that's an error that is
maintained between the two additions and
I I think as I said the only one so
let's let's explore that a little bit
first of all in the kinds of places
where this book is most useful were you
to go into a local shop and find
vegetable oil it would almost certainly
be something like sunflower canola
canola it's going to be cheap and highly
industrialized exactly it's going to be
exactly the the culprit oils and indeed
I mean if I'm thinking about in
Madagascar in in Maran satra the town
nearest
um where I did most of my research they
were often the oils were in these giant
oil drums right and then you bring in
like an uh like an empty water bottle I
got I know like a one of these crinkly
plastic water bottles that you you know
bought at the store you drank the water
and they basically dump it into the oil
bin the the oil can
this big drum of
God knows what vegetable oil and that's
that's your cooking oil so I have I
never had and that was you know that was
in the 90s that we were doing that I
never had any sense that that was
actually going to be good for you yeah
it's troubling from multiple different
uh levels and I would just point out
that you know that oh it's a big drum of
something thing gets even worse for the
transportation of some of these things
they're transported in these big ships
and you know the uh the controls that
actually render that safer uh certainly
not sufficient
um but the you know
the distinction between let's say Olive
and avocado oil which you're almost
certain not to be able to find in one of
these little shops because they're you
know luxury goods and canola or
safflower or whatever you are going to
be able to find has to do with you know
the subtle distinction that in the case
of those two oils that are good right
which seemed like they would be seed
oils aren't seed oils because it's not
the seed from which the oil is extracted
these are it's the fruit it's the fatty
fruit olives and avocados have very
fatty fruits and it's the fruits of the
olives and the fruits of the avocado
with which the oils are being made yeah
and the same thing actually it's it's
different I don't know why it's
different for coconut is the exception
yeah and why it's an exception I don't
exactly know either but
um but in any case the
you know the diagram is referring to
something accurate there's a correct
piece of logic there which is an under
nutrition problem for many developing
World children right a high volume
starchy food may have you know uh
sufficient nutrition in one regard but
it's so high volume that the point is
the net nutrition that one gets out of a
meal may be below the necessary
threshold
um but what you do to correct it is uh
not wise in the case of the way that
piece of advice would be interpreted by
somebody given what's locally likely to
be available well and I'm thinking
you know
my experience and our experience as well
in northeastern Madagascar a very remote
part of an already very remote island
nation in the western part of the Indian
Ocean where rice is the food people eat
rice three times a day often only rice
you know enough so that the you know the
national drink is burnt rice water
and it's it's you know and you know when
when you meet someone on the street one
of the formal exchanges is how many
bowls of rice have you eaten today and
the higher the number sort of the
greater indicator of wealth that you
have I don't know if that is still the
case but it was back in the 90s
and in in the particular spot where I
was doing my research I was on the coast
of course because I was on Little Island
right off the coast of of Northeastern
Madagascar
there are a lot of fishermen in these
little pierogues these little you know
cut up you know
wooden wooden boats that they were
paddling Dugout canoes
and they would go out fishing for some
number of days at a time before coming
back to their families with with their
catch but it being the tropics fish
doesn't save that well
and so in fact on the shore of nosy
mangape the island where I was working
on a few other places too there are
these Fisher camps where they would uh
dry and smoke the fish and the the two
conservation agents who were on the
island one of the years that I was um
that I was there got very excited when a
fisherman would pull up and you know
offer to sell some of some of their
smoked fish to to us uh because we would
we would eat together it would be you
know them and me and my field assistant
or the year that you were there with me
um the five of us a different field
assistant and you and me and then two
conservation agents and occasionally a
couple of malagazi uh wild pig
researchers as well it was a small group
tiny Island and uh the first time that
these smalligazzi fishermen pulled up I
thought oh thank God I guess we're gonna
have something besides rice right and
you know we can we can we can have some
fish but what is done is the fish is
smoked Because unless you eat the fish
the same day you catch it goes bad in
this tropical climate the fish is smoked
but you don't then eat the smoked
effectively salted dried fish no you
boil it into water and you pour the
reconstituted reconstituted smoked dried
fish broth onto the rice and you eat the
rice that now tastes a little bit of
fish
and to a western palette to a privileged
Western palette it's not good
so it's not good but it is patently
nourishing yeah right it is patently
more nourishing for you than just the
bowl of rice that you would otherwise be
eating and while I never came to think
it was delicious I did come to associate
those moments when we managed to acquire
some of this smoked dried fish and then
um you know having watched what the
malagazi do like okay this is what we do
we make the broth out of it we pour it
on the rice like well okay
um I'm fed I am fed
When in Rome When in Rome right so
that was the rare mistake from the
earlier Edition that is not corrected in
2022. uh some changes between the do
editions that suggest what I'm calling
creeping stupidity
uh in let's see here in the 1992 Edition
on page 126 there's nothing to show here
because I didn't pull it up we have a
section
um in a chapter
let's see I can't remember what the
chapter is called the chapter is
basically about what you should be
eating and how to stay healthy and
there's a section called fat people
to be fat to be very fat is not healthy
it begins okay that same section in the
2022 Edition you want to guess
that's the same section called in 2022.
it's it's not terrible like it's it's it
didn't go full stupid but it's creeping
stupidity I think that same section same
page like again they really did make it
easy to compare editions here
um in the 2022 Edition are called people
who are too heavy to be very fat is not
healthy very heavy people are more
likely to get high blood pressure Etc so
they didn't actually change any of the
conclusions they just took out the word
fat
yeah actually that one
okay so
um in 1992 there was a section
on uh fertility
in which they wrote men and women who
are not able to have children
etc etc and they changed that phrase in
2022 to people who are not able to have
children
some of whom are men and women well no
actually in this case so oh just
intersects people like you know what
intersex people are generally not going
to have an easy time having children and
if they are then they are doing so as a
man or a woman so it's men and women who
have children not some third imaginary
sex right so that's just
creepingly stupid actually uh words like
sterility have been removed I don't know
why they're talking about sterility and
they just like use different words now
and
sex is often disappeared but not always
even in chapters entirely about
reproduction so for instance in 1992 men
are sometimes unable to make women
pregnant because they have fewer sperms
than usual
a person may make fever sperm than is
normal and so be unable to make someone
pregnant
why like just just why do it all the
chapters on sex on pregnancy and
childbirth on Family Planning and there
are a lot of them in here have removed
some mention of male and female in
places but they've left in others so
it's just a mess it's just going to be
more confusing to people who are trying
to use this as an actual manual for you
know Village Healthcare it's it's it's
silly and it's actually potentially
bordering on dangerous because you know
no one who lives in a village who's
dealing with fertility issues or
childbirth issues or yeah or any of this
is actually confused about who it is who
gets pregnant and who it is who has the
sperm like they're just not confused
about it all right
this is interesting because you can
imagine that in whatever context it is
that the revision was decided upon the
details of what would be changed
that a conversation probably unfolded
where well if we adjust the language so
that it can't get us in trouble
it doesn't actually
anybody who reads it is going to know
what it means so but they didn't do it
completely well but never mind that
let's say they did but they didn't
doesn't matter let's say they did okay
if they changed everything so that
nobody who disbelieves in two Sexes
would be offended right but anybody who
did believe two Sexes would know exactly
what was being said then you could argue
that the meaning hadn't been lost
however
especially in places where such a book
might find itself the idea that the
language is going to appear to dance
around a fiction that's actually
biologically settled and not complex
right is dangerous and I want to tell a
little anecdote
um as I've mentioned before my first
research gig
was in Jamaica and it was a fascinating
experience I lived in a little town
didn't have there was not even a phone
line into the town and I was looking for
cell phones with four cell phones I was
living with a Jamaican family and I was
brought into their world and I actually
got to see how their world worked and
they took me in as one of their own
which was a lovely and formative
experience for me
the children of this extended Clan so I
was in this house that had a yard but
the family was related to a number of
other houses
so they were I don't know probably 10
kids who followed me around and were
interested because I would talk to them
about my life which was very different
from theirs they were very interested to
hear what I had to say and I knew things
I was a science student and anyway so
they would ask lots and lots of
questions
and you were a decent human being and as
and a stranger in a place with uh with a
closed tight-knit group and you were
accepted and so hey yeah talk to the new
guy it was it was yeah
totally totally cool except for one
incident where
um
I was reading uh I think it was the
unbearable lightness of being
you were written kundra and okay I was
reading kundra and that was fine but um
I got I think to the end of the book and
I I can't remember the book very well
but um there was a very sad poignant
moment and I was fending off tears and
the kids were like interested to come
talk to me and I did not want to cry in
front of the children and anyway so I
was like moving into the bush trying to
find a place where I could finish
reading this book and be done with this
but anyway
um
yeah but anyway so I got a lot of
interesting questions from these kids
and they were very revealing some of
these questions were brilliant questions
that really made you think about things
and some of the questions were the
result of the very provincial
circumstances that these kids were
living in and one of the very
unfortunate facts of their existence was
that the weekly world news remember the
weekly world news this is like a tabloid
that would show up in the yeah it was a
tabloid Supermarket checkouts it used to
be I don't know that it still might
still be but it used to be available at
supermarket checkouts but it was the one
right The National Enquirer was the one
that kind of pretended to be a newspaper
and Report real stories that were super
Sensational and the weekly world news
was for people who had given up on
reality and it was just the most
outlandish stuff right like you know
woman gives birth to space alien was
literally one of these things somehow
every so often one of these things would
land in this little piece of Jamaica and
it looks like a newspaper and so it's
news from the United States right
they've got it going on how tragic is it
to have something broadcasting insane
nonsense that it's not even clear if
it's a joke right into you know Back
Country Jamaica where there's nobody to
say yeah let me explain to you what that
newspaper is so you won't take it so
damn seriously if you see it yeah um so
anyway okay into that milieu you've got
this insane newspaper that Finds Its way
into these kids hands and this book also
might well be in such a place right all
right and so my point is if this book is
skirting around some issue of gender
that makes it seem like oh even the
medical people are you know being very
careful not to say men and women maybe
this is real maybe there are more than
two Sexes right then the point is it it
reinforces that rather than just saying
the damn truth yeah and you know
okay there's a truth but it hurt my
feelings okay see Ben Shapiro about that
right but um
so anyway with reality and get back to
me or don't right so I guess I guess
what I'm comparing was there a
particular incident that you that you
wanted to relate yeah yeah I think it
was it was actually this question of
woman gives birth to space alien and
they wanted to know if this had in fact
happened it was like I mean how would
they know that it didn't right but how
if let's suppose that I hadn't been
there and they hadn't asked anybody who
could straighten them out on this issue
you might think well I don't know that a
woman gave birth to a space alien but it
did read it once did read it so I have
to leave that possibility open well how
much education the kids the kids were
literate were they are they reading this
yeah they were in school yeah and uh as
I've mentioned before they were
bilingual without realizing it because
they spoke Patois and English yeah and
which made me frustrating to them
because but they thought they only spoke
one language right they thought it was
one thing because they moved seamlessly
between them and I
spoke English very well and struggled
the whole time with Patois and so when
they would say things to me in Patois
and I would not understand them they
would be like
what are you dumb are you what are you
doing like stop that you know what we're
saying and so anyway it was it was a
fascinating experience but if you
compare the high-minded uh you know
discussion at the publisher surrounded
by white boards around the big laminate
uh conference table in which they
decided what to delicately change in
some way that left the meaning there for
whoever wanted to find it yeah and then
the harm done where this book finds
itself into the hands of somebody who
just wants to know what the hell is
going on and the book implies by being
very strange with language that men and
women are that's not those categories
aren't as good as we once thought and
some fool has told them the same thing
right that's that's a tragedy the book
just needs to be straightforward it's a
medical book designed to tell you what
to do in the absence of an authority
that's its purpose exactly
exactly okay
um just a couple more examples of some
changes that I find suggestive of
creeping stupidity and then we'll talk
about the ways that their um their
recommendations around vaccinations have
changed
uh in their chapter how to stay healthy
during pregnancy or the section called
how to stay healthy during pregnancy in
1992 they say continue to work and get
exercise but try not to get too tired
in 2022 try to rest more but also get
some exercise
now most people probably just go right
by that and not even notice that there's
been a change the fact that so much in
these two editions is unchanged makes it
really really clear that that is a
change and it is a bad change it is a
stupid change the idea that now you're
basically telling pregnant women they
are you know delicate fragile precious
flowers who are going to do themselves a
service by trying not to do too much and
definitely not continuing on with their
lives and that's actually in all but a
few cases going to result in worse
outcomes uh you know the less fit you
are as you go into childbirth the more
likely you are to have complications so
you know try to rest more but also get
some exercise it flips the the thing
that you should be prioritizing on its
head now I could see
I could see a possibly feminist argument
for for getting rid of the first framing
which was continue to work and get
exercise but try not to get too tired
you know continue to working at exercise
definitely you know get down there and
scrub the floors because that's your job
woman I don't read it that way at all
and frankly I think that the the move
away from encouraging women to continue
to do what they do while they are
pregnant until they can't anymore
because there does become a point where
just like just get this out of me I'm
just I'm done here
um it's it's anti-feminist actually this
is this is this is a dangerous thing uh
which we see in our culture moving women
away from being you know we were moving
in the right direction of you know what
you know you're different men and women
are different and there's going to be
different constraints and different
possibilities and you can try for
anything you want and also if you if you
are going to get pregnant and have a
child there are going to be limitations
on what you can do but don't limit
yourself on the voice of an Authority
from outside listen to your own body
listen to you and listen to your Kinfolk
like listen to your mother and your
sisters and your Midwife and your Doula
and you all of these people and say you
know what I feel like I feel like I
should be walking right now then go walk
like that's what you should be doing not
taking a book that is decided you know
what try to rest more but also get some
exercise it feels like it flips which
should actually be being done yeah it
actually sounds conservative but it's
radical yeah right yeah and it flies in
the face I mean and this is really
frankly a problem for medicine as it is
currently understood it flies in the
face of obvious evolutionary logic yeah
right yes the answer is to the extent
that you should be limited by pregnancy
and you should alter what you're doing
you're probably programmed to know it
especially with respect to activity
right right it's one thing with respect
to a modern food that your ancestors may
not have encountered and therefore you
might be sensitive to something and you
wouldn't have a detector for it or
whatever but with respect to something
that every single human female ancestor
did while pregnant up until five minutes
ago the answer is you probably have an
internal guide to how far you can push
it and listen to that listen to that and
so you know I guess what I'm
what I'm getting from this is there's a
lot of stuff in medicine that instead of
taking the
um
do not disrupt that which works that
that should you know that's like above
even the Hippocratic Oath right it's
like the central principle don't disrupt
something that works right just because
you think you know how to make it better
because you're not going to make it
better yeah right don't make the mistake
of chesterton's fence right so as far as
things that aren't working what you
should should you do you should try to
restore the conditions in which the
body's natural ability to fix this thing
functions to the extent possible right
and then there comes a point at which
you don't have a choice right you've got
a tumor for whatever reason cutting it
out of you is the mechanism using
antibiotics to prevent infection at the
site it all makes sense but the basic
point is there should be a strong bias
in the direction of doing what made
sense uh in ancestral times not
disrupting those patterns as much as you
can avoid disrupting them being
especially cautious about development
um intervening as little as possible as
being as sparing as possible and if it
should show up anywhere it's in this
book and it is here in this book in some
ways but it's the greatest yes that bias
is strong and exists in this book in a
good way but it is disappearing a little
bit and and there's one notable
exception which I'm about to get to
which is which is for the guard to
vaccines but just one more example from
their sec section called how to stay
healthy during pregnancy in the 1992
Edition they say avoid taking medicines
if at all possible full stop that's
that's the advice in 2022 they say they
say avoid taking medicines and they take
out the if at all possible and then
later in that same little bullet point
they say get up to date on vaccinations
and test it for HIV
and the increasing recommendation for
women who are pregnant to be getting
vaccinations is concerning to me and I
have not seen I don't know if it exists
a good history of what recommendations
have been made when I have increasingly
been hearing in fact just this week we
have a friend who's pregnant who asked
me I said I've been recommended that I
get this thing during pregnancy this
vaccine and you know my sense 20 years
ago when we were using this 1992 version
of this book long before I was pregnant
or thinking about getting pregnant was
like that's not that's not when you do
that you go into pregnancy healthy and
you don't put new
achievance and introduce new possible
pathogens into you at that point like
that's not that's not what you do no it
and the fact is it speaks to the same
hubris right what are the chances that
medicine understands the placenta well
enough to know how it is going to react
to a vaccinated mother
right I mean a I would just point out
the
developing fetus is spectacularly well
insulated from pathogens by a very
ancient mechanism right so
the question is okay is the mother more
vulnerable during this period is the
mother's illness a greater threat to the
growing infant than the novelty of the
intervention right these are complex
questions and the idea that medicine has
looked at them carefully studied them
figured out the answers and it turns out
that a cost-benefit analysis makes it uh
better to vaccinate a pregnant woman
than to hold off
I don't believe it no I don't I don't
believe it either yeah and I think um
there is a there is a larger burden on a
pregnant woman or a woman or a family
with a newborn to work harder to not be
exposed to certain pathogens and it can
feel constraining it can feel unfair if
what you thought was every human should
have access to exactly the same choices
and decisions about how to spend every
moment of their time as every other
human well that's not true like if if
that's your sense of why it's unfair
then you then you've just been you know
betrayed by reality and there's nothing
to be done about it so you know if
you're pregnant you should work harder
to avoid pathogens then when you're not
pregnant just as if you're
immunocompromised like I'm sorry that
you're immunocompromised and that that
puts a greater burden on you
that happened and now it is more
important for you than some for someone
who is not immunocompromised to work
very hard to avoid pathogens same thing
when you're pregnant same thing when
you've got a newborn and doing so
behaviorally through your own choices of
how to move around the world as opposed
to imagining that
um you know these reductionist
anti-evolutionary
non-thinking uh you know doctors can
deliver unto you a magic shot or a magic
pill and that will solve all the
problems those things don't exist and
you know I say that again as someone who
is you know enthusiastic about
vaccines in general and enthusiastic
about antibiotics in general and there's
just a lot of moments when neither are
the appropriate move and the 1992
version of this book did a very good job
of saying
uh you know their you know children
should get these recommended
vaccinations and uh and that will help
protect them against these these very
debilitating diseases and what has
happened in the 2022 Edition on this
question is is a little bit shocking so
before I go there uh let us
show the second picture if you will Zach
so I read from last week how injections
can disable children and this is the
section that I read from that I'm
showing now
um
one out of every three cases of polio
was caused by injections they say in the
1992 section they specifically say to
reduce the chance of paralysis from
polio it is best not to give
vaccinations immunizations or any other
injections when a child has a fever or
signs of a cold this could be a mild
polio infection without paralysis okay
and show what that same section looks
like in 2022 if you will Zach that's the
third picture it's exactly the same
section and it's one of the very few
sections of the book which looks very
different although it's in exactly the
same you know it's the same section so
they've taken out both the image of
three three children three children with
polio one of whom they are attributing
to haven't gotten some kind of an
injection
and they've taken out all mention of
the fact of vaccinating when you are
already sick vaccinating a child when
the child is already sick potentially
causing trouble they have taken that out
they've removed it why I don't know but
they've taken it out well we have to
leave one possibility open here and I
think with poly I mean I don't know and
I I uh I would like to to look into it
but
the nature so in the case of one in
three cases of polio may actually be
vaccine induced what they're likely
talking about is the case of an
attenuated vaccine that has a bad
interaction with a latent infection they
are so and not necessary they're not
specifying actually if I if I read both
the lines in between the lines they are
not restricting uh in the 1992 Edition
their claim that one in three are up to
one in three polio infections may
actually have been caused by an
injection they're not saying that one in
three would have been caused by a polio
vaccination they're saying an injection
which is to say that it's possible that
a low-level sickness that a child has
could be polio and that sometimes it is
in these cases where polio is still
endemic and that getting any kind of
injection that has any kind of effect
like an adjuvant that's going to trigger
the immune system will cause that
polymer infection which the child would
have been able to fend off and then be
immune to it to blow up into a lifelong
debilitating disease yeah well if that
is the case if that's really the
implication there then it hints at a
very important fact which you and I have
become increasingly focused on as we've
thought more and more about the various
different Technologies involved in
vaccines and so-called vaccines
um but the idea of hey some manufacturer
needs to get more of a reaction out of
the immune system because what it's
giving you is very weak T antigenically
and so it's going to use an adjuvant to
wake up your immune system how good is
it to wake up your immune system what
happens if your immune system is
reacting to something else at the same
time which it often is and you may not
be aware of so anyway so and when you
think about it this way like okay should
I take should I take a shot or an oral
vaccine for instance the purpose of
which is to engage my immune system when
I am sick with something else does would
that ever make sense
right it it seems actually kind of clear
that that is something that should be a
common sense piece of advice wait until
you feel in perfect health wait until
I'm gonna make some numbers up you know
a week two weeks after the last time you
felt in any way sick before you get
something on board before you take
something on board the purpose of which
is to inform your immune system and of a
particular pathogen and aggravated
enough that it hops to right if your
immune system is already responding to a
cold or a flu or God forbid you know a
low-level polio virus it's already
engaged and now it gets some other
injection that the purpose of which is
in part to get your immune system to
kind of you know get flustered get
active
if their original numbers are right that
is extraordinary that you know what this
is and it's an it's another reason we're
going to get back to like um vandenbush
is like you do not vaccinate during a
during a pandemic right you do not
vaccinate against a thing when that
thing is circulating right uh because
it's you potentially make it worse
because there is going to be some
ability for some number of people and we
don't at all fully understand why people
vary so much but for any given disease
exposure to that disease is going to
result in very different kinds of
illness across the population yeah it's
also true that to the extent that there
is something called a safety test that
actually has the capacity to find
risks the number of people involved in a
safety test who would have been sick
with any one of the dozens of things
that they might have contracted is going
to be tiny so to the extent that this
vaccine and this illness are a bad
combination a it's almost certain to be
missed B
um that risk is always there and
therefore the idea of well should you
take a vaccine vaccines are safe suppose
a vaccine was perfectly safe which I
don't believe they ever are but a
vaccine was perfectly safe except in
people who were sick with something that
does circulate right right so that some
tiny number of people who happen to be
sick with something maybe it's you know
the first day of their illness with
something else and they don't know that
they're sick yet right and they get a
vaccine the point is you're taking that
risk inherently when you say this is a
vaccine worth taking this should be
factored into the calculus what are the
chances that some parameter like am I
sick with something else is going to
change the safety of this vaccine in my
particular case on this particular day
if that exists for every vaccine right
then the point is oh well there's a
reason you shouldn't want to have the
number of vaccines be arbitrarily or
large in the first place even if they
were all safe right because the point is
and that you shouldn't simply follow a
schedule like well if he's three months
old he needs to get it but he's got he's
got a cold nope if he's three months old
he's got to get the thing I'm gonna wait
until that child is healthy right or may
you know as you also as long as possible
as you and I have talked about there are
lots of things that potentially could
have influences on the hazard of of
these sorts of Technology that are
simply not discussed right if
myocarditis is a risk does it matter
which arm you're injected in probably
and therefore why is that something you
know that is left to the clinician or to
the patient to decide right why is that
not an issue
if it is true that being sick with
something
changes the risk that accompanies a
particular inoculation then is there a
season in which inoculating is safer and
therefore should there be inoculation
season and no-go season right yeah maybe
pollen season isn't the right season to
be inoculating people perhaps it isn't
maybe it's true that vaccines are an
incredibly potent weapon against
infectious disease but that they are
dangerous enough that what should happen
is you should have a blood panel that
decides whether or not you appear to be
sick with something you don't know about
that might affect how safe the thing is
before getting any inoculation right the
point is there's a whole landscape of
possibilities in between these things
are too unsafe to contemplate and these
things are so safe that you are a bad
person if you don't get one yes that
that binary being of course trotted out
as anti-vaxxer and vaxxer right and
neither of those positions make sense
anti-vaxxer and decent person which is
not a die-cut all right
okay so let us walk through how
specifically the recommendations for
childhood vaccines change between these
two editions you can show my uh my
screen here Zach I just I created a
document
which I went through the two books and
compared the recommendations and I
walked through the recommendations last
week uh from the 1992 Edition this is
all you know easily found page 147
um in 1992 there were four vaccines
recommended they've got six here for
young children
um they got DPT which is diphtheria
whooping cough and tetanus polio
BCG for tuberculosis measles just the
single measles shot and then those are
those are the Early Childhood vaccines
that the 1992 edition of where there is
no doctor recommended and then they've
got tetanus for older children
and which incidentally in 2022 here you
see that that's just kind of wrapped up
into number one so they've got nine
recommendations but they've actually
cheated by combining one and five from
before because the T in the DPT shot is
a tetanus shot so you know consistently
where there is no doctor says you know
tetanus is the thing that you really
have to worry about and you really want
to be protected from polio tuberculosis
measles and smallpox being the others
smallpox they said and I didn't actually
catch this when I was talking about it
last week they mentioned in the 1992
Edition but they said the disease has
been eradicated so you don't need this
anymore so they actually had five
recommended vaccines in um
in
in 1992 for young children and in 2022
they still have DPT
and polio and BCG for tuberculosis and
measles although now they say maybe it
should also be maybe instead of measles
it should be the MMR shot
which is the triple measles mumps and
rubella
and then they add a whole bunch more
so in 2022 we've got Hep B which and I'm
just I've got in quotes here what
the
what the 2022 Edition says about either
the disease or the pathogen that is
identified as being dealt with by the
vaccine is what it does
so Hep B is described in the 2022
edition of where there is no doctor as a
serious liver disease and they say three
or four shots simultaneous with DBT Hib
which is hemophilus influenza type B
um which quote causes meningitis and
pneumonia three to four shots again
simultaneous with DPT plus a booster
you've got number seven here
pneumococcal conjugate against pneumonia
three shots again simultaneous with DPT
got rotavirus which is apparently quote
against a diarrhea disease that can kill
young children that's an oral vaccine
like the polio vaccine and then HPV
which they don't specify but I believe
they're not giving that to young
children anywhere so I gave them the
benefit of the doubt here and did not
put that into the young children
recommendations this is human
papillomavirus which quote causes
cervical cancer and some other Cancers
and I counted up the shots too and in
where there was no doctor
recommended for young children five
shots plus oral polio vaccine and three
additional shots for older children in
the form of the tetanus shot and in the
2022 Edition they're recommending 15 to
17 shots depending plus oral polio and
oral rotavirus and for older children an
additional five to six shots
that's a big change
and when I go looking just a little bit
at what how effective these new vaccines
are whether or not they are actually
doing what they're claiming to do
whether or not they are definitely
necessary all the places that they are
being advocated for whether or not
having all of these at once which is
probably more about compliance than
about health right now if you're a rural
health care worker and you've got
someone with a baby and you are
convinced that they absolutely need for
the health of their baby to get them
this full retinue of vaccinations it is
going to be much harder to get that
mother with her young baby and she may
have other babies at home other children
at home and she's got a lot of things
going on it's going to be harder to get
her to come in 15 to 17 times
than it is to get her to come in three
four five times right so if you have
everything on the same schedule as the
original DPT vaccine the diphtheria
pertussis and tetanus vaccine and you're
taking the Hep B shot the same time in
the hip shot and the pneumococcal
conjugate shot and the rotavirus oral
vaccine all at the same time
well most of these vaccines have
adjuvants in them don't they
and so you're just ramping up that
immune system of that young child in
some cases so young that they are if
you've taken the other advice in this
otherwise excellent book
um completely that child is still only
an exclusively breastfed that child is
still being protected
largely by the breast milk of their
mother and receiving immune information
from their mother
there is
a lot to wonder about what has changed
in these recommendations and this is not
a match for
the childhood vaccination schedule in
the U.S indeed the childhood vaccination
schedule in the U.S is is more than this
but I don't
I have not yet
heard or read or thought of
an explanation for an increase in the
childhood vaccination schedule this
extreme that makes evolutionary or
medical sense yes and the mechanism for
knowing is available to us and
um does not appear to be deployed as a
rationale right an all-cause mortality
benefit of both the individual vaccines
and more importantly the schedule as a
whole right if you adhere to this
schedule are you better off in terms of
how long you're going to live than if
you didn't right that's an important
question because as you point out let's
say you have a shot and let's say that
it was tested in isolation because of
course it would be
and it has the correct amount of
adjuvant if there is such a thing or
inducing the correct amount of response
in the immune system to produce the
correct uh reactivity
okay now you give somebody multiple
shots at once okay well probably if the
correct amount of adjuvant was some
quantity that was activating enough of
the immune system then really you only
need the adjuvant from one shot because
the activated immune system from that
one shot is sufficient to activate the
immune system for the antigens in the
other shots so unless unless the
argument is oh actually you need you
need that because you need the immune
system responding to you know Hib and to
DPT and all of these things in which
case that's an argument against taking
the shots at the same time yeah right
right exactly and so I guess let's put
it this way
you and I like so many others bought the
story surrounding vaccines and you know
I believe that the story The Jenner
story about smallpox and cowpox is a
very powerful story that talks about a
very potent mechanism for actually
reducing infectious disease we are
believers in the idea of vaccination but
the radical program in which we take
many diseases and vaccinate a young
person from them effectively sending
that person's immune system the message
that they are in this environment full
of these pathogens just attacking them
you know at an incredible rate right is
that safe
nobody knows could we find out we sure
could but there's a question is the
explosion in the vaccine schedule driven
by our having developed vaccines that
are in isolation worthwhile are they
still worthwhile in conjunction or is
this motivated by shareholder value and
the fact that standards of care can be
used to get doses of things administered
to people and what happens to those
people is actually quite secondary
yes I I wonder very much the same thing
so a couple more things here with regard
to changes in this again mostly
excellent book where there is no doctor
between the 1992 and the 2022 Edition at
the very beginning of the 20 of the 19
excuse me of the 2022 Edition
there was in the 1992 Edition a uh
section on thanks a whole page of
gratitude basically acknowledgments
it's gone in the 2022 Edition instead we
have an entire page devoted to covid
covet 19. yeah makes me feel that way
too yeah
um
it it has some things here that are true
and accurate descriptors of what we
think we know about coven but it also
says uh
it says a lot
um
vaccination there are several vaccines
for covet 19. all prevent serious
illness or Death and All are safe the
sooner you get vaccinated with any of
them the sooner you will be protected
and the sooner the disease will stop
spreading after six to eight months you
will also need to get a vaccine booster
injection to strengthen your resistance
to copen19
prevention against covid-19 getting
vaccinated is the best way to prevent
covid-19 infection until vaccines are
available to everyone you could take
steps to protect yourself and others
and then they direct the interested
reader to a lot of online content I'm
going to share just a little bit of that
that they that they have created that
Hesperian the publisher has created with
regards before you do
again
nothing in that advice
is risk stratified for age or health
status now there is some risk
stratification in some of the stuff
online they got a lot of stuff online
okay there's no doctor but you
definitely have access to online ideas
if you want to find out about the risks
for adaptation right good point okay so
let us uh show my screen if you will
here Zach this is a PDF that I pulled
directly from online I'll link to um
I'll link to these these two documents
in the show notes this is Hesperian
Health guides which again is the
publisher of this book covid-19 vaccines
there are now several vaccines for
covert 19. uh oh actually I think this
is just exactly the same as the section
I just read they're all safe it's all
good just do it right vaccines are safe
and effective they say vaccines work
you and many people you know have been
safely vaccinated against many illnesses
because of vaccines some illnesses that
used to harm or even kill people such as
polio and smallpox are now rare have
disappeared completely
here we have the same trick we have been
talking about basically since we began
Dark Horse right where they take a
category
and a word that describes that category
and it's meaningful and then they say
I'm gonna I'm gonna take that word and
I'm going to apply it to something else
and I'm going to tell you that if you
don't unders if you don't believe that I
am telling you what is true then you
don't believe in the category itself and
that is that is a faint that is a bait
and switch that is cheating and that is
dangerous so I'm going to continue
reading from this here Zach
the covid-19 vaccines were developed so
fast how do we know they're safe
all vaccines are tested to make sure the
vaccine is not harmful find the best
dose make sure there are no serious side
effects and make sure it is effective
the covid-19 vaccines have been tested
by more than 250 000 people in many
different countries people of different
ethnicities with various existing
illnesses and have a wide range of Ages
after many months almost no health
problems were reported from any of the
new vaccines
huh that's why the covid-19 vaccines
were approved quickly
now the vaccines now have been used by
millions of people around the world with
very few serious side effects reported
much of the research developed these
vaccines was done before the covid-19
epidemic began
outbreaks of other coronaviruses in 2002
SARS and 2012 MERS drove the development
of new vaccines and vaccine Technologies
to stop them
this and other research worldwide
quickened the development of the
covid-19 vaccines
so
this it's it's stunning like this is an
excellent book
what have they done what what has
happened well I mean the number of
Errors there and they're subtle right
a lot of things that are factually true
there right right the developmental work
on these vaccine platforms may have
followed SARS one right but it doesn't
mean that they had a vaccine that was
being tested it wasn't fast we already
had it in the wings wait you did how did
um yeah no you didn't and the idea of
you know very few side effects were
reported well have you looked into
theirs I mean you know the yellow card
system what the hell is going on but
anyway look
I don't know what to make of that but
it's like a religion managed to insert a
page into this book which indicts the
entire book because the thing is
um
where there is no doctor
a Village Health Care handbook that can
kill you
if you don't understand risk
stratification and uncertainties
involving new medical Technologies right
and I just never had the sense about
what was in the earlier version of that
book at all well but I mean it is
conspicuous there are people let's call
them young men right okay young men who
are healthy and do experience a
significant risk of myocarditis and I'm
telling you it's going to be other
pathologies as well but we've spotted
the myocarditis we all get that it's
there that it tends to be more a risk
for young men who are healthy and also
not in danger by covet the idea that a
medical advice book does not say you
know it's questionable enough that this
is a proper thing to do from the point
of view of decreasing all-cause
mortality for people who are older and
do have morbidities but for young people
who are healthy especially men the idea
that there's just a blanket
recommendation that they are safe that
there is no mention of the difference in
how safe they are depending upon your
health status and your age and there is
no mention of the difference of the in
the threat of covid to you over those
things is medical malpractice so what is
malpractice doing in this book yeah so
um there's another just from the same
document here something I wasn't
planning on reading but who should get
the covid-19 vaccine hmm
everyone should get the covid-19 vaccine
when there is not enough vaccine for
everyone it makes sense to give the
vaccine first to the groups of people
most at risk of getting sick
health workers workers who joke some of
them into contact Elders people who have
illnesses or disabilities
that's it it's just about when there's
not enough and separately they argue
that you know the you know one of one of
the great health care discrepancies of
our time is that the
developed world countries got the
vaccines first and this is a
terrible
a terrible Injustice but I think that's
also a tell right the idea that the
logic of risk stratification is there
because the risk of the disease is
stratified and they acknowledge it and
there's no mention of it with the
vaccines tells you what is this about uh
sounds like it's about Demand right to
the extent that there's not enough
vaccine so there's not enough supply for
the demand the point is oh well then we
can talk about risk stratification right
but to the extent that there's plenty of
vaccine it's for everybody and boosters
right the point is that sounds an awful
lot like what we're talking about your
shareholder value and not about human
health yes so the publisher Hesperian
has a new book coming out um
it's called new where there is no doctor
I don't know what the relationship of
that book is to this book because this
2022 Edition is pretty new I'm thinking
maybe it's not the same author I don't
know
they've got some Advanced chapters
available online for new where there is
no doctor and I just want to share a
little bit from their vaccine chapter
that they've got available online again
for this is the this is the new where
there is no doctor as distinguished as
distinct from the 2022 edition of where
there is no doctor
vaccines prevent illness
they go through how do they work how do
they work how do they work
vaccinations work
vaccines are safe
I'm going to talk about a little bit of
the other stuff in here but they make
these again blanket statements vaccines
work vaccines are safe
this is an eminently gamable position
and with covid we saw it gamed I don't
know how often we've been gamed before
convince everyone that vaccines are a
good
I'm convinced
put anything that you want everyone to
take into a category called vaccines and
then behind the scenes kind of change
the definition of vaccines or maybe
don't even worry about it because most
people aren't tracking
once you've called a thing a vaccine
vilify anyone who says I'm not taking
that
I'm not at risk for the disease it
prevents against it doesn't actually
prevent against the disease you say it
does it's not safe and you couldn't
possibly know it is so I know you've
already lied to me any number of reasons
that you might not want to take
something that they have decided to try
to shove down your throat by calling it
a vaccine this unfortunately does the
same trick vaccinations work well I
believe
that I have seen evidence that some
vaccinations work
vaccinations don't work across the board
right yeah it doesn't match either the
history of vaccines that have been
tested and failed or the vaccines that
have been released and recalled exactly
same with vaccines are safe
so you know people
are better than this are smarter than
this and when you simply put falsehoods
in front of them they trust less and
less and this like this
was an amazing resource and I think
largely still is and again this this
little section is from a different book
that's about to come out with an almost
identical title what if my child is sick
when vaccinations are scheduled
remember so this is the last thing I'll
do here and then I'll get off this topic
for now
um remember the conversation we just had
and what was in the 1992 version of
where there is no doctor which says
don't don't give immunizations when your
child is sick because something like one
in the three cases of polio may actually
have been produced by injections that
were given when the child may be already
had a low-lying case of polio that then
got you know shot into a really bad
territory by the fact of the terror but
the fact of the immunization here we
have in a not yet released book an
advanced chapter online of new where
there is no doctor what if my child is
sick when vaccinations are scheduled
vaccinations can be given to someone
with a cold or minor illness
if a child has a serious health problem
the health worker will tell the family
if a vaccination should be delayed when
others in the family in the community
are vaccinated it will help prevent
sickness in those who cannot receive a
vaccine
they seem to be reversing
not just disappearing the previous
advice but now reverse in previous
advice
vaccinations can be given to someone
with a cold or minor illness no I don't
think they should be no
and if a child has a serious health
problem the health worker will tell the
family if a vaccination should be
delayed what are the chances again
that a health worker in a rural area
with a family that has made a long Trek
and at Great expense personal monetary
everything to get to the health clinic
is going to say not today come back in a
week
because for the most part that family is
not going to come back in a week
healthcare workers are not going to even
even if they were informed and
increasingly there's less chance of them
being informed because now they're
getting told things that aren't true but
even if they were informed about the
risk of giving immunizations to sick
children they are really unlikely to say
I can't do that now I can I can you know
I can immunize the rest of you but not
not little Timmy because he's sick right
now
yeah and you know going back to our
conversation of a few weeks ago even
just saying you know vaccines are safe
hey guess what that's another violation
of Nuremberg right there right just a
casual violation actually and I must say
it's a little hard to know what exactly
goes into giving such rotten advice
um but the
uh I find it sort of Despicable that we
have people in the first world who know
that that sentence can't even be true
who are dispensing that advice to people
in places where they don't have the
ability to check it against anything
right and uh
anyway so there's a
I don't know I don't know what it is I
don't know if it's a class if you were
uh whatever other kind of arrogance it
might be but there's something very
wrong with dispensing uh
dispensing unnuanced information where a
parent has an absolute right to know the
truth as we understand it which is maybe
at best this vaccine is understood to be
safe enough that it is worth whatever
risk comes with it right but this is
just you know vaccines are safe there is
no defending that statement it is not a
true statement and one more thing yeah
just one more thing here um I don't know
my screen may have blinked out but it's
okay uh this is again the the bottom of
this Advanced chapter on vaccines
um to be published soon in a book called
new where there is no doctor the number
and type of vaccinations have changed
compared to my first child why
for some diseases more than one
pharmaceutical company makes a vaccine
that is safe and works well
they may have different schedules so if
two countries use a different vaccine
brand or the same country changes from
one to another the schedule of
injections may change too
other changes happen when a new vaccine
is created or an old one is no longer
needed
there's a lot to unpack there
the thing that I want to point out is
that presumably
I would have assumed that most of the
reason for the vaccine schedule to
change the childhood vaccine is
scheduled to change is because we now
have vaccines against diseases that we
didn't have vaccines against before and
to some degree like with smallpox and
polio we've actually fully eradicated
them and so you don't need the
vaccination anymore at least for for
money many of us
but that
um that part of this answer comes last
the bulk of the answer the majority of
the answer here to why does the vaccine
schedule look different than it did for
my first kid
is it's about Pharma like they just put
it right up at the front it's about the
pharmaceutical companies and they're all
safe and effective we know that and they
just sometimes have different schedules
and so maybe your country used to be
getting theirs from Merck and now it's
getting it from uh you know AstraZeneca
who can say but it's fine it's fine that
seems to be sort of the overall like
don't you worry you're pretty little
ahead about it uh it's you know yes
sometimes there's new vaccines sure but
really it's about the pharmaceutical
companies and they got your back so
we're good well look I hate to have
fallen into a well of cynicism and I'm
doing my best to avoid it but you know
once you spot this issue of Pharma
having this deeply perverse incentive
right Pharma masquerades as wanting to
create Health but of course its bottom
line is facilitated when there's ill
health or threat to health that demands
um its products
one thing that is true you know I was
surprised to see in that little
description if the vaccine is no longer
needed oh that's a guess we've defeated
a disease it doesn't sound very good for
demand so I guess what I would predict
well but I mean that's consistent with
um smallpox like the the 2022 edition of
the original book
um doesn't have smallpox mentioned at
all whereas the 1992 Edition mentions it
and says actually we've done this we
we'd been there we did that you don't
need this anymore right but my
prediction then is if what we are seeing
is a medical landscape that is actually
being driven by
uh fiscal considerations inside of
Pharma which I increasingly believe is
the dominant player then
um you would imagine that we will stop
at any potential to drive
um
pathogens to Extinction that are the
basis of demand for pharmaceutical
products will at least not happen while
those products are under patent that in
fact the ideal for uh for Pharma
is a vaccine or something that
masquerades as one and therefore gets
called things like safe right that does
not block the spread of disease but has
some credible claim to being desirable
so that it will be made into the
standard of care and in a really good
week for Pharma will be inflicted on the
public under mandate right that's what
you want it's something that doesn't
control the disease because the disease
is after all the reason for the Demand
right and you wouldn't want to go around
curing diseases because you know you
that would be the naive Pharma thing to
do so anyway my prediction is we're
going to see an awful lot of the
explosion of schedules of standard of
care for items that happen to be
profitable and then we'll see
Shenanigans like we discussed I believe
last week
where a perfectly viable drug has now
been put into a new triple cocktail that
is now suddenly again Reviving The
patentability of the thing right you're
just going to see endless versions of
the same game and
um anyway I would love to be proven
wrong but yes I'm not expecting it yeah
I'm where I'm where you are on that okay
that is my um you extended update on on
the update on where there is no doctor
all right we're going to switch gears I
have a number of topics I want to talk
about I admit up front it's a little
hard for me I know that they connect in
multiple ways but how to present them so
it's clear is not as obvious to me but
I'm going to start by suggesting that we
are in
a moment that is nothing if not
bewildering right that the number of
things that seem off kilter
counter-intuitive broken
deceptive all of those parameters are
have been turned to 11. and I believe
that's going to get worse the llm AGI
issue is going to amplify the confusion
large language models artificial general
intelligence for those who aren't
keeping track of every single acronym
that is being thrown at them all the
time is correct but anyway we have
talked about the fact that one of the
several disasters that is likely to come
out of the llm AGI era that's large
language model artificial general
intelligence is human confusion that the
inability to know how authentic the
thing that you're interacting with is
whether it's a person reporting what an
llm told them or you know somebody who
doesn't even didn't even talk to an llm
who's had their perspective altered by
some intrusion into the online
environment is going to cause us at best
to all become very cynical and not
believe anything which is a recipe for
disaster this is that era yes okay so
what we have argued up till now is that
basically it would be great if there
were some rules that you could apply
that would at least do a substantial
fraction of the heavy lifting of
figuring out how to think in this era
right that's really the label for this
segment how to think right and I can't
tell you how to think but I can tell you
that we are making progress towards some
things that are useful in the context of
artificial intelligence we have given
two rules that are useful one of them is
that you should take all of the things
that you formerly assumed
that are in some way affected by the
existence of these large language models
and soon to be AGI if it's not here
already
and you should go back to making no
assumption right you don't have to
change your assumption about what's true
of the elements on the periodic table or
the forces of nature or natural
selection as it explains the existence
and modification of creatures because
those things aren't affected by the AI
but what we believe about the facts of
the present is going to be affected by
this dramatically and so the point is
things that you could safely assume a
few years ago are no longer safe to
assume you'd have to be agnostic about
them and then to the extent that you
want to take them back on as assumptions
you need to check them specifically
right that's rule one
rule 2 is treat AGI itself like a new
species right like something arrived
from somewhere else and you know nothing
about it this is important because as it
happens the way AGI seems to be showing
up in the world or threatening to Dawn
it is going to have access to the human
API that is the mechanism by which the
human mind is contactable from the
outside human language right the llms
are going to have access to human
language because that's how they work
so instead of assuming that a statement
by one of these entities is Meaningful
in the way that it would be if a person
said this to you you should be agnostic
about what it means about what's going
on internally because you don't have any
mechanism for knowing how the thing
thinks and therefore treating it like a
totally new species is the best you can
do right it's hard to do in practice but
it is the best you can do
okay so that's two prototype rules
here's a realm artificial intelligence
here are two rules that you can apply
straight out of the box that will make
you better off than if you didn't have
those rules right there may be other
rules we should add to that list but for
the moment we've got two rules and they
constitute some sort of a baseline
approach
I want to suggest that there's another
realm where we can deploy a rule to good
effect
we saw
a new chapter of the UFO slash UAP
story Dawn this week again with the use
of the PS and the A's yeah UFO I got
unidentified flying object
um UAP
aerial aerial phenomena unidentified
aerial phenomena I think basically a
synonym it's it's a it's a fancy
sounding synonym for UFO I think you're
giving it too much credit it is a
rebranding of UFO and I believe that I'm
not the one who used it yeah no no
you're giving it credit by saying that
it's a euphemism and my feeling is UFO
had taken on a certain Fringe
connotation and that somebody decided it
was time to have responsible people be
ready to talk about these things in
polite society and so it needed a
refresh the brand had to be reintroduced
to the market and lo and behold Kentucky
Fried Chicken which sounded stagey is
now KFC and it sounds edgy right UAP
sounds a whole lot more responsible than
UFO despite describing the same damn
thing
that's what I think
but in any case so I don't want a new
planet I want all of them to find a new
planet
is good I know just the one yes yes
do you oh you know the one yeah
it's not ready yet
Mars
all right you don't care you don't care
if it has an atmosphere I I
oh yeah but okay
so you can hear the cinema so UFO yep
yeah uh so UFO UAP three letter acronyms
on and on the the phenomena here you're
gonna employ you're gonna suggest a rule
for dealing with okay they got a
rebranding they've rebranded we're
supposed to take it seriously now oh yes
it's a serious stuff now um but the the
rule is what you might use to look at
the news this week something new
happened in the land of uaps what
happened we have a highly credible
Source who has turned whistleblower and
actually now has whistleblower
protection testifying under oath that
the federal government
has multiple alien craft and dead Pilots
of those craft it possesses them
which is huge news
unless it's not true in which case it's
huge news of a different kind but now
you have to live in a world where you
can't figure out which of those two it
is okay
Schrodinger's world
Schrodinger's UFO Pilots I mean I feel
like but I I think the llm AGI situation
is producing like Schrodinger's reality
everywhere like you there's so many of
these where we where
she's like I just can't know and and for
some of them like you know what no I'm
just like if that's if that's true then
then I I don't care like I'm done so I'm
just gonna go with this one but so many
of them is like I really have to keep
these simultaneously these mutually
exclusive things alive at the same time
you are stuck in a Quantum superposition
nightmare yeah okay so this is why you
need a rule okay what's the rule
um the rule is
Psy up until proven otherwise okay now
this rule is something I don't know it's
a rule about the null hypothesis right
it's a rule about the burden of proof
yeah
um and this is either generated in
concert with Jeremy riss who was a guest
on Dark Horse or maybe it's his and uh
because we introduced it into the
podcast together it doesn't really
matter let's say it's Jeremy's and he
he's uh do full credit for it
nonetheless the utility of the rule is
the following thing
what we have are a lot of phenomena
which are increasingly difficult to
dismiss right a
person with proper credentials turning
whistleblower on programs that
apparently house and attempt to reverse
engineer alien aircraft and have in
their possession multiple dead Pilots
right
that's hard to ignore because what you
know what has to be true for that story
to be garbage
okay a lot
on the other hand
story is kind of hard to swallow without
physical evidence that would at least
make Earthbound scientists
stand up and take notice because it was
not explicable by the Material Sciences
that we are aware of the biology that we
are aware of for example and so the
point is something like this
first of all there's an awful lot of
eyewitness accounts of very profound
stuff happening in our skies right I
don't know how much you've looked at it
but amazing things right craft trans
moving across space at incredible speeds
turning at rates that not only defy
physics but reason right why I mean why
are the aliens flying like this
I mean because they're teenage boys I
don't know no all right I have a better
hypothesis for this one okay no wait no
I know I okay but I haven't these aliens
are worse than I ever was okay
they're worse than I ever say to that no
they are look I can prove it okay I can
prove it okay
the aliens
why are they turning that way right
surely there's a better way to do it
okay look but forget it okay you guys
you defend this maybe it's a rental
they've got a collision Dam and Galactic
collision damage hell yeah but no I
still I still have you right where I
want okay okay great
okay on this planet you say I was that
guy at one point a younger person
I'm just saying a lives I mean I I was a
tiny bit how many know it like how many
vehicles have I totaled
it
these aliens are totaling vehicles in
Nevada like nobody's business right what
look they are yes that's where the
government got these warehouses full of
alien cars always in Nevada that's not
always in Nevada but there is a look are
they interested in the prostitutes
what's going on I can steal man this I I
learned well from my friend Jeremy riss
okay okay the Steel Man of the argument
that the preponderance of these things
is you know in places that you know
Americans might find entertaining
has to do with the fact that nuclear
tests were performed here first and
therefore the beacon that we sent into
the universe that said that we are ready
for uh punking by the aliens which is
apparently what they're doing because
let's put it this way we've got now
Decades of observation again see earlier
comment about their teenage boys
they could the teenage boys punking us
but they're not good at driving right
they have crashed a lot of these craft
according to this new witness Okay so
anyway
look well here's what I'm really telling
you okay we can do this all day long am
I telling you there are no aliens No in
fact I'm telling you that everything I
know as a biologist tells me that there
most certainly are aliens what I want to
know the question is one of Locale yes
have yes look I could be wrong about
that maybe we're the only life in the
universe and if we're not the only life
maybe no other intelligent life ever
escapes the technology uh the
development of the technology necessary
to get here but if there are aliens have
we been visited and are we being visited
right and I think I mean this this that
part of this argument will be clear to
almost all of our listeners but let us
just be very clear right forever as long
as I can remember and I think is
probably as long as you can remember too
like I think both of us you know we met
each other when we were quite young but
already before we met at like 16 when we
were we became friends
um we both understood that we believed
that they're almost there had to be lots
of different evolutions of life in the
universe some of which would be sentient
actually including in the Galaxy they
don't they don't have to be but the
probability signature this is the
probability suggests that is the case
that that we are not alone but we are
not alone
is a is a phrase that often
gets said and then the assumption is
that you're not saying the part about
like right here
and the we are not alone conclusion
never imagined that that meant like
everyone's here because the it's the
scale both space and time of yes the
entire universe but even just of our
galaxy that allows biologists in
particular but lots of other people to
say you know what almost certainly yes
life has happened elsewhere but
it's not here well we don't know I'm I'm
open to it any day of the week that the
aliens want to settle this and here's
the thing aliens who want to show off in
our skies and not show up and talk to us
about what it is
don't make a hell of a lot of sense to
me I'm not saying it's impossible but
there's no reason for aliens to be
revealing themselves zipping around our
skies and crashing into our deserts
without actually showing up and saying
look here's what we've got to tell you
or you know take us to your leader or uh
resistance is useless or any of the
other things that they might say right
right so the point is we've got
anomalous aliens who are very interested
in
um causing a problem for small numbers
of people who have these encounters they
can't shake and other people who look at
them like they're nuts why are the
aliens doing that
if the aliens want to talk let's talk
and if they don't want to talk then the
question is are they really aliens or
are they something else right hence
hence the rule the rule the null
hypothesis is
we are alone here
no the null hypothesis is the
observation in question the report in
question the video in question is a
psyop until proven otherwise so the
conclusion is the same but your framing
is specifically around what is that then
the rule is sigh up until proven
otherwise right and again my point is
about the thing which you whoever you
are are putting in front of me or
whoever else if your point is how do you
explain math my answer is Psy up until
proven otherwise the moment you show me
something where psyop is not an obvious
possibility I'm all ears I'm not saying
that there aren't aliens who would be
interested in us and come by they might
are they barred from doing so by physics
we don't know we sort of think so but
you know people who know better than I
do think those rules may not be as
absolute as we thought okay I'm I'm
totally open to the possibility of
aliens but I'm sick and tired of be
precise here yeah I'm totally cool with
the idea of aliens showing up here and
actually I almost think it's one of the
few things that might break us out of
our terrible trajectory so there's a
part of me that's hopeful for it but
I'm sick of pixels
I'm sick of eyewitness reports of
aircraft that do amazing things and make
no noise right unlikely now of course
the psyop can start introducing noise
sure can I mean we saw what I think is a
really garbagey version of this whole
thing uh where there was a 9-1-1 call
from a family who had something crashed
in their backyard there were aliens
eight ten feet tall the police came the
police had caught the object falling out
of the sky on a whatever you call it a
body cam right so you know the story
like superficially is like whoa the cops
caught it on their Cam and these people
are calling saying they're aliens
standing around their backyard they seem
to have forgotten to film them I don't
know maybe these people don't have cell
phones
um but uh they didn't catch it they
report that the aliens when they you
know that there was an alien hiding
behind a forklift and uh the the young
man was it a biped that's the
implication now nobody seems to have
thought to draw a picture of what they
saw which I can't quite explain
um stretched out humanoid right no doubt
because that's always what the aliens
look like right so you know I don't know
maybe they're maybe their bowel plan
constraints are great enough that it's
more limited you know how I feel about
that of course but I'm open to us being
wrong about any of this I just want
something that constitutes actual
evidence where the most parsimonious
explanation is not someone would like
you to believe there are aliens right
when that's the most parsimonious
explanation my point is my guess is if
there are aliens and they're coming here
I'm likely to miss them by 100 years a
thousand years
would be a while right the idea that we
just happen to be here and you know
Trump and aliens are happening at the
same time right it's like
okay maybe you're just trying to get me
excited that's what you're doing you're
feeding me story after story that I
can't resist thinking about because you
don't want me thinking about
I don't know uh corruption and Ukraine
or something right I don't know but
anyway the rule George Floyd trans it's
a never mind
it's a never-ending sequence of stories
that makes us feel like this is the
moment when it's all happening and um
anyway so I happen to approving
otherwise and I welcome that it is
proven otherwise as soon as possible but
you know really you got I'd like to know
you got two entities that can do it the
aliens can do it any day they want to do
it and the government can let somebody
into that warehouse you know so we can
talk about what technology it is or what
materials it is that can't be explained
uh as Earthly in origin and better still
the alien Pilots
because that here you're not talking
about technology that we just don't know
the government has biology at the point
is actually biologists might be able to
look at that and say Earthly or not
right or biological or not yeah
um
okay so that's the setup you need some
rules that allow you to take care of
your Quantum superposition problem and
sigh up until proven otherwise is the
one to use for uaps and I would advise
all sorts of people to use that rule
because I believe that to the extent
that something wants us to believe the
uaps are really extraterrestrial in
origin it is especially interested in uh
important people
okay
now I want to move into the second phase
which is that I'm
in terms of trying to get people to
figure out how to think so that the
world is less complex and I can make
some kind of meaningful useful sense
from it that they can actually navigate
their lives I want to talk about a
category that I have spotted which
I think it needs a name and I don't know
it but the category is
important Concepts that are
destructive in the way they are deployed
right so these are Concepts that you
don't want to dispense with because they
matter but the way they are being
deployed is more harmful than it is
useful
um so let me give you some examples the
right side of History okay the right
side of History to me is
an incredibly important concept right
the Nazis were on the wrong side of
History right you want in retrospect to
have been on the side that opposed them
and as early as possible Right
the same thing can be said for the
segregationists right you don't want to
be on the side of the segregationists or
those who defended
um Jim Crow laws or any of these things
the right side of history is obvious in
retrospect okay that said declaring
yourself on the right side of history is
uh
not a
simply interpreted move in other words I
certainly live my life trying to be on
the side of history that will be
understood to be the right side of
history in retrospect correctly
understood correctly understood but
saying that you're on the right side of
History isn't evidence one way or the
other and we can take the example of
so-called affirmative care right
the affirmative care folks some of them
I believe to be cynical and some of them
I believe to be very confused the
confused ones just specify affirmative
care means that when a child declares
that they are the sex that they are not
but not when they declare that they're a
donut uh that they are definitely the
sex that they are not and that you must
affirm them in every way that you can
right unless they think they're a donut
right in case you don't and you don't
even you know the state of California is
experimenting this week I don't believe
this has become law of the State of
California but they're experimenting
with a law uh in which parents would be
obligated to deliver so-called
affirmative Care at the indication of a
child that they were the not the sex
that they were thought to be which to me
is the height of diabolical
um but the point is to a person truly
confused about this issue yeah to make a
person want aliens
right
um enough with the psy up bring on the
aliens okay
um
so the point is the person who thinks
that they are protecting a child who is
going to be harmed by not receiving
affirmative care that person thinks
they're on the right side of history and
they are certainly not but the point is
both sides of History one or the other
of these is going to be the right side
of history for certain right because
either these are people in desperate
need of help or you're about to maim
them while thinking that you're helping
them okay so that's one concept the
concept is important right side of
history but the abuse of it is uh very
troubling and common
second one I would say is the you might
have seen the formulation you know
this person's this person is a dumb
person's idea a smart person
now
I haven't run into this okay the idea
that there are people who are not smart
but their Niche is to behave as people
who aren't very smart
will understand them to be smart that is
a particular kind of a con right so oh
I've seen faculty do it a lot sure oh
absolutely actually it's an epidemic
inside of the academy there are lots of
people who aren't smart who you know
have the affectations of somebody who is
deeply learned and knowledgeable yeah
chalk on the elbows yeah the whole thing
um
so there is a real thing a dumb person's
idea of a smart person okay and there
are probably more decent ways to put
that right Dom is a bit provocative but
whatever but you will then see you know
on Twitter for example somebody will say
oh name a you know a person who is a
dumb person's idea of a smart person
right and then you will get a flood of
answers including me and you and Joe
Rogan and Jordan Peterson and all sorts
of folks and the basic point is ah this
is a trap
if you put this label on somebody dumb
person's idea of a smart person and then
somebody looks at it and they think wait
I thought that person was
I guess I must be dumb right so the
point is that thing is like you know
it's a sure it's a trick in order to
keep you from listening to somebody by
claiming that if you think what they say
is good then that's an indictment of you
right you don't get to do that you
didn't buy their stuff did you right oh
God anybody who doesn't understand you
know anybody who doesn't understand you
know that uh Heather highing is a you
know a faker who you know obviously
didn't earn a meaningful degree in
biology right the point is uh
no that's not true but you just you've
just leveled an accusation well it again
it reverses it again with the null
hypothesis it reverses the null
hypothesis yeah yeah I mean it's not
it's not perfectly that's not a
perfectly clean analysis but
um the idea that someone who has begun
to listen uh to to you or to me or to
Joe Rogan or to Jordan Peterson or to
any number of people and has begun to
get something out of it has begun to
feel themselves awakened perhaps and
begin to take on new kinds of analyzes
that maybe they couldn't before
but it's not conscious and we're not
writing curriculum here and so we
haven't provided a list of like these
are the things that you can now do and
these are what you know these are the
changes that you will see in yourself
and so if someone lobs and especially
into social media space and again like
I've never seen this because I'm
blissfully unaware of most of what goes
on there someone lobs into that like oh
you're not buying that are you
like well but I I was being I thought I
was more aware and being transformed and
no there isn't now that you see that
there isn't anything that I can actually
point to is there and it's not the job
of the person especially who is learning
Anew how to do a certain kind of
analysis or view the world through a
particular lens and then through a
different lens in a different lens
to back up and say here is a list here's
the list of things that I you know I
have learned which demonstrate to me or
that she has said or he has said or they
have said uh that demonstrates to me
that they're actually smart like it's
it's no one's obligation to demonstrate
that someone from whom they are learning
is actually smart if they are learning
from that person then it is effective
well it is that is true and
the the fact that as you try to struggle
out of this argument it gets worse and
not better right if I say oh I'm calling
your bluff I think Heather hiring is
very insightful then the point zone
right so the point is the more you
insist that this person actually is
smart the more you indict your own in
intellect and ability to discern right
and so the point is that's just
logically unfair yep right that I simply
disagree cannot be the argument that
calls your own intellect into question
right so anyway it's a it's a it's a
it's a Chinese finger trap or it's a
mistnet the more you struggle the worse
it gets for you that's not a fair
argument
um okay now
the the one that I wanted to focus on
most though is the concept of controlled
opposition
okay so somebody leveled this accusation
at me this week you need to Define it
first well that was the question what
does it mean okay so controlled
opposition superficially means that this
person is uh on the correct side of the
argument but that they are actually more
useful to the people on the other side
of the argument because they either
provide a tepid version of it or they
will reverse their position at the last
minute they will do something so you
know if um
if the CIA killed John F Kennedy right
and it didn't want us to know that it
might have somebody in the world of
researchers who study this question who
deployed part of the evidence for this
but cast doubt on other even more
important evidence or just somehow
polluted the question or
um you know turned out to have something
in their history that made them
unreliable so that people who glommed
onto their version of the story ended up
embarrassed whatever it was okay so
here's the problem
controlled opposition is a very real
phenomenon okay sophisticated actors use
controlled opposition to keep us from
getting where we need to go in
Civilization so it's a very important
concept you wouldn't want to live
without it in this era
that is an accusation
it's diabolical and here's the reason so
I asked after this person accused me of
being controlled opposition I asked my
Twitter followers does that accusation
imply the person in question would be
knowledgeable that they are controlled
opposition or might it be true without
their awareness
there was near Universal agreement that
the person in question would not have to
be aware
right that you could be controlled
opposition and not even know
so now we have a meaningless term right
are we controlled opposition because
YouTube tried to manipulate us into
altering our message about covid
remedies by demonetizing our Channel I
think they certainly tried to control us
but it didn't work right we kept doing
what we were doing so are we controlled
opposition because somebody desired to
control us or are we not controlled
opposition because we resisted in which
case when you see this accusation
leveled at people the question is well
what are you really saying are you
saying they're being successfully
controlled are you saying that somebody
has put them on a list on a board
somewhere and decided to try to control
them it's a completely unfalsifiable
meaningless way to dismiss people who
are on the correct side of an argument
which also means that it is
an unfair kind of competition to the
extent that all of us are trying to put
a message into the universe that we hope
people will find valuable and there's a
limited amount of attention the idea
that you can just take somebody who is
doing a better job of that than you are
and say oh well that's controlled
opposition you wouldn't want to listen
to them right the point is well it's a
devastating argument it's just that it
didn't require anything of you like
evidence right you just said the fact
that that person is making sense is
evidence that you shouldn't listen to
them it's like well because they're
making sense I shouldn't listen to them
well that's what controlled opposition
is they make sense and you shouldn't
listen to them because somebody else has
decided it's in their interest for you
to listen to this version so the point
is it's like you know it's like you know
dumping LSD on an argument right it's
not going to clarify anything right
so
anyway my point is this this category
I'm building are arguments or terms that
are important but where the use of them
is actually highly destructive right and
my three examples were controlled
opposition the right side of history and
a dumb person's idea of a smart person
yep
um so anyway it's probably a much bigger
category oh undoubtedly undoubtedly a
huge category and
um I mean I think you know the language
games
are
cheap
and so powerful and the return on
investment is incredible yeah the return
investment is huge and you know we see
we've already talked earlier in this uh
in this episode about you know other
ways that language is is played with you
know from the eradication of using male
and female when talking about you know
who's getting pregnant and who's
impregnating uh to you know oh what we
have to do first is to make sure that
everyone understands how important and
valuable vaccines are and then all we
have to do is just call anything we want
a vaccine and then we can vilify anyone
who doesn't agree with that piece well
you're an anti-faxer so it's not the
same kind of language play but it's
similarly cheap you know in the in the
case of in the case of what is being
done to the concept of vaccines it
required a decades-long investment right
to make sure that the vast majority of
us were on board right that we actually
agreed the yes vaccines are a good our
societal good and that we appreciate
that they have helped
so I don't you know it totally open
question one that I have not really
given any thought to as to whether or
not what is happening now with the term
was imagined at any time in the past but
it was just waiting there easy pickings
like oh well now that we've got everyone
almost everyone on board with the
concept of you know the the vast utility
of vaccines all we have to do
is just shove a bunch of stuff into that
category that that isn't right and uh
yeah at some point probably people will
wake up but hopefully it'll be a while
so
I think
what we are honing in on is
language
is a you know I've called it earlier in
this uh in this podcast the human API
right
there is cognition human beings are
unique in the ability to pass
abstractions from one mind to the other
and have them be you know erected in the
new mind in a reasonably complete form
how is this done through an absolutely
miraculous process where one person
literally vibrates the air molecules in
some way they don't even couldn't
explain how they're doing it and it
lands in a little membrane in the ear
and the side of the head of the other
person and Wobbles just so that precise
meanings are transmitted between people
who share the same code
right that's stunning but the point is
that thing that is exchanged the words
the vibrations that are used to transmit
them or if it's on a written page the
organization of pigments so that people
can deduce the the symbols in question
those things are not the meaning this is
a version of the map is not the
territory right the language that we use
to explain an idea is not the idea right
right and so what you really describing
actually post-modernism makes the the
map as the territory error yeah actually
it really is analogous I think I hadn't
thought of it in those terms before but
I think it really is yeah and so the
idea is look if you have an antagonist
who wants to tangle your thinking so
that you become helpless what they do is
they
subordinate in fact they
disassociate from the meaning layer and
they descend into the language layer the
means of exchange and they tangle it
with sophistry they game the language so
that you cannot make sense and if you
can even manage to make sense to
yourself you can't make sense to the
next person because they've placed all
these booby traps and uh and the point
is you know one of the rules that we
need to
um
to
name to codify has to do something with
an obligation to the underlying reality
where language is simply a tool used to
get there and what we should do is seek
to clarify our language such that we can
talk our way out of the Trap we find
ourselves in together right to the
extent that the language is getting in
our way and we're fighting over
definitions and all of these things the
point is all of that is beside the point
we're destroying the meaning layer while
we're fighting over the language layer
and really the meaning layer you know
nature bats last the meaning layer bats
last right our confusions about sex and
gender are not going to result in a
language catastrophe they're going to
result in a Developmental and
reproductive catastrophe
and that has to be Paramount right we
have to we have to restore that idea
that the real world exists and although
most of what we do as humans is done
through the language layer it's not what
any of this is about
okay so the last part of what I wanted
to
do is talk about a couple of things that
emerged into the news this week one of
which is uh highly Sensational and the
other one is
almost entirely obscure I think they're
both very important
but in this new space where we are
trying to
figure out how to make sense of the
world despite the
um the Hall of Mirrors that is being
constructed around all meaning
and so the two the two things are the
indictment of President Trump
or the
um
I don't even know what the term is for
it his taking of classified documents to
Mar-A-Lago
obviously a sensational story this is a
I believe that this is the only case of
a sitting or former president uh
indicted for a federal crime anyway for
those who want to understand more about
the legal nuances here I would recommend
Glenn greenwald's
system update from yesterday where he
explores this
um but let's talk for a minute about
what it means and what the proper way
the proper context to be thinking about
it might be and then we'll get to the
other issue which is much more obscure
but I think potentially as important or
more so
so first of all
there's a question here about The
Sensational fact of President Trump
being indicted for a crime that could
literally put him in prison
um
there's a question about how to think
about the issue legally and it is far
from a straightforward situation right
the man did have the documents and they
were classified but there are nuances
here which are incredibly important
one of them is that the president has
the authority to unclassify anything
that the president wants to unclassify
at any time the president wishes to
unclassify it and so if it is true that
the president took classified documents
and was not entitled to he also had the
power to make himself entitled to so at
some level it's like a clerical question
he didn't file the right papers to be
allowed to take the things that he took
but he had the right to file the papers
so is that something worth putting a
former president in jail over
doesn't seem like it that's one piece of
context that I think is very important
now I did ask illegal Authority
is there a procedure that he was
supposed to go through that he might not
have so he would be technically guilty
of this crime and what I was told and I
will check it with others and make sure
that we're all on the same page about
what is being said is that there
actually is no procedure and so if
that's true then how does a president
declassify material well maybe he treats
it in a way that it's not classified
maybe he takes it home
right maybe he's just simply not guilty
on the basis that what he did
Declassified the documents and therefore
this is just all nonsense
right that's one important question it's
a lot of nonsense regardless oh there's
a lot of nonsense I mean
second issue is
Joe Biden
did the same damn thing
okay except for one thing okay Joe Biden
took documents home that were classified
right so we've got a selective
prosecution question here why are we
Prosecuting Donald Trump and nacho Biden
but it's worse by about a thousand times
you know why
because when Biden did it he was vice
president without the ability to
declassify the documents exactly so it's
in fact if I understand it and again I'm
always open to being corrected by people
who understand this landscape better
than I do but if I understand this
landscape Joe Biden committed a crime
Trump arguably didn't and
that we would be prosecuting Trump and
nacho Biden is conspicuous
um
further
this is a moment at which Joe Biden and
you know maybe this is all happening to
distract from the fact that Joe Biden
appears to have taken five million
dollars in what sure looks like a bribe
in the same scheme in which Hunter Biden
took another five million dollars uh
surrounding barisma energy and Ukraine
so we're talking about a president who
appears to be guilty of some very
serious consequential stuff
um influence paddling which frankly I
must have said a hundred times during
the 2020 election as we were trying to
advance the idea of unity 2020. I kept
saying look Joe Biden is a non-starter
why he is an influence Peddler and you
can't have such a person as President
right you did
um and so okay lo and behold five
million bucks to the big guy okay and
that turns out to be the real deal and
it's not five hundred thousand dollars
it's five million dollars that's a large
amount of money and there is now a war
in Ukraine and none of us know how any
of these things fit together but
nonetheless we should be very seriously
concerned about the Biden family
influence peddling and at the moment
what we seem to be concerned about
is the appearance that Donald Trump
seems to have taken documents that by
some analysis he wasn't entitled to take
but even the people who make that
analysis would have to admit that he had
the right to take them through some
other mechanism so it's like an you know
it's like a nothing Burger without even
a Patty right
it's the ultimate nothing burger right
yeah
um okay but
so I find this story fascinating I find
the selective prosecution aspect of it
absolutely maddening and the idea that
if there is a crime oh by the way uh one
of the things that Glenn Greenwald is
very clear about in his system update
is that Washington official Washington
classifies stuff
just out of reflex it classifies all
kinds of things that have no reason to
be classified and so even just the fact
that all classified documents were taken
does not mean that these were highly
secret important things it just means
somebody marked them secret right so all
right all of that is very interesting
and then there's the second question
which is
um
why
would the elites be playing this game
right for one thing
ah maybe I don't get it but I feel like
they are playing directly into Trump's
hands in an election in which there are
a lot of other ways to go if he got to
run from prison man this is born to be a
martyr I mean frankly I've never voted
for the man I'm not planning to vote for
the man but they are making an argument
for voting for him that is getting ever
harder to ignore which is that they are
so terrified of him that they will they
will use anything to stop him including
a completely flimsy legal argument that
could land him in jail which would ah
the whole thing doesn't make sense so
you know it's like okay
we agree
that there's a terrifying bear outside
the cabin
and the DNC has a plan to deal with it
it's going to go shoot the bear and so
it grabs its BB gun and it empties the
BB gun into the bear and the bear
notices and now what right like no it
you why did the DNC assures us we cut
more babies well we do I have got so
many babies I gotta Wonder
I mean look okay is the DNC trying to
elect Trump because they're afraid of
Robert Kennedy Jr they are afraid of
Robert Kennedy Jr I mean I don't even
know if I'm kidding right this is a dumb
plan for dealing with a guy like Trump
this is playing right into Trump's hands
is it possible I mean I've said and I
was not kidding that I believe the DNC
fears Robert Kennedy Jr much more than
it fears trump it would rather live
under a trump Administration than deal
with Bobby Kennedy Jr in a position of
power
um so this would be one interpretation
of what's Happening Here I don't it's
hard for me to imagine that they would
do that
but here's here's where I come out on it
I don't want to vote for Trump because I
really don't think he's the right guy
for that job I do think he is facing he
is revealing he is the story that
diagnoses the system right Donald Trump
is a terrible problem for Elites because
he's his own Elite and he doesn't listen
to them right so the point is to the
extent that they've got a nice little
racket going they do not want this
particular bull in a china shop or
wrecking ball or whatever your metaphor
is for Trump yeah and so the point is
they will break out all kinds of exotic
stuff
you know they will uh whatever happened
to the actual election they will
certainly move outside of the election
and do things like suppress important
stories about Joe Biden's son right so
you know a conspiracy does exist against
Trump that forces you to think about
Trump in some different way that's a
very unfortunate thing for them to have
done
but here's here's the punch line
Robert Kennedy Jr and Donald Trump are
both threats to the underlying thing the
anti-democratic unpatriotic thing that
exerts this kind of control right
they're both a different kind of elite
and that doesn't listen to The
Establishment yeah but Kennedy has
um gravitas and knowledge and
statesmanship and depth
let us say at the very least
Bobby Kennedy has a
um
an excellent knowledge of History
I believe he has clear Integrity that he
is not obsessed with aggrandizing
himself in fact has paid very heavy
prices to do what he believed to be the
right thing in the face of incredible
pushback and so
um
we have two versions of a threat to
something that is reacting in a way that
reveals just how vile it is
they would go after you know a former
president with a flimsy argument over
his possession of documents that he was
entitled to take if he wanted to right
that is
um appalling and you know we are we are
historically stuck with a question right
are we what kind of Republic what flavor
of Republic are we to have are we to
have a Democratic Republic or a Banana
Republic if you like banana then you
know we can play these games and we can
go after each other's presidents with
exotic legal theories and you know
nonsense and you know gotchas and
whatever or we could try to actually
govern in the interests of the people
the way the founders decided that we
should do it and I think we are at the
moment where we get to choose and my
feeling is whatever it is that's doing
this has to go and the question is by
what mechanism right do you want the
wrecking ball in a china shop or do you
want
um the
passionate careful
uh student of History who
um yeah
um okay I know which one I want yeah me
too
um second piece here uh the news story
that I said was very important but has
gotten very little press
it is today the 9th of June 10th 10th of
June 10th of June which makes Monday the
12th am I right
Monday is the 12th the 12th is as I
understand it the first day of the
largest NATO
air exercise in history it will begin
begin on Monday in Europe
involves hundreds of different aircraft
and
it you know in addition to being the
largest exercise ever by NATO it also
has at least one very unusual feature so
I believe the exercise is something that
is done periodically maybe even yearly
with this Defender 23 exercise is going
to include the Japanese this time right
this is NATO North Atlantic Treaty
Organization the Japanese are not in the
Atlantic And as far as I know they are
not moving to the Atlantic so this is
odd that they would be included in the
exercise it could send a very
interesting message to China
that's the possibility that this is
about some piece of History yet to
emerge
um it also is strangely juxtaposed by
the fact that the luftwaffe yes the
liftoff of that luftwaffe the German air
force
is in charge of this exercise which all
suggests that this is a rather dangerous
and how often are the luftwaffe
in church
this story has barely been reported and
I can't understand how it would not be
right the very fact that we have a very
hot War being fought in Ukraine
that that war is at least
um
at least exists in the context of the
Russians having
extracted a promise that we would not
expand NATO to the east which we then
did so what role that plays in the
invasion of Ukraine I cannot say but I
can say that NATO and its expansionist
instincts are relevant to the conflict
in Ukraine and in the middle of that
conflict in which one of the parties is
our Cold War adversary with a ferocious
nuclear Arsenal that we are engaged in a
military Flex the largest NATO exercise
of its kind in history that we put the
Germans the enemies of the Russians in
charge of it we've invited the Japanese
on the Italians are they coming
I I don't know I should have checked I
assume that they're involved I don't
think they have the biggest Air Force
but they're also not in the North
Atlantic so they should be true but
anyway I don't know but anyway the point
is look
let's just even just run a little
thought exercise
if NATO decided to move a huge force of
aircraft to Europe at this moment right
it would be noteworthy does this have
anything to do with what's going on in
Ukraine is this defensive or is this
offensive right those are questions that
are legitimate to ask dare you sir right
yeah instead what we've got is an
exercise
you know is NATO moving aircraft to
Europe yes
right exactly so anyway
as always I am completely open to
information that would tell me I am
seeing a mirage but I do think
from my perspective having read you know
articles in out of the way places about
this happening that we are engaged in a
Undeclared Flex against Russia in the
middle of a hot war in Ukraine and that
that is at least something that we would
want to think very carefully before
doing because the last thing we want to
do is take this highly kinetic war and
turn it into a nuclear Exchange
right NATO flexing on the doorstep of
Ukraine at this moment is
a topic that should be much more
discussed than I hear it being and
anyway that's my point why is this
hiding outside of our site as if nothing
is going on because it's obviously
something Defender 13 is what it's
called yep okay oh no Defender 23. oh
Defender 23 23 way off who knows what
Defender 13 is
don't know maybe it happened in uh I
don't know 2013 yeah perhaps uh well
yeah I have I really don't know what to
say so I'm not going to comment at the
moment I that's
more Insanity tell me I'm overreacting
you know I
I hope I am I can't do that yeah I only
know what you've told me here
uh you said you said a few things to me
about this yesterday but I have not I
have no independent knowledge of any of
it
it doesn't
it doesn't seem to make sense can we at
least agree that it's weird that it's
not
um
news in light of what's going on in
Ukraine yeah
yep yep
all right well I hope I'm overreacting
um maybe we'll get through next week
that'd be cool
this is why people are interested in
talking about aliens
of course for which we have a rule yes
yes and I think that that rule applies
not just to people trying to make sense
of the situation it also makes it
applies to aliens trying to make sense
of the situation
yeah well the fact that they have
employed that rule if if they're in fact
here they have employed that rule and
they've gotten through their version of
whatever stupid we're living through
right now like they they did it they
figured it out I mean they're a
space-faring species or more than one
yeah yep
oh my God okay
okay well that was long um but we
promised a q a today so we're going to
take a break uh we're gonna do all of
our post amble stuff here that's usually
a preamble and and then we're gonna take
a little break and we're gonna come back
with a q a but we're going to try to
keep it brief because that that went on
for a while so if you want to ask
questions
excuse me uh you can go to
darkhorseimmissions.com to ask your
questions
you can also find us find me at Natural
Selections
um
where I write
um weekly or nearly weekly about things
such as this time this week I was
writing about different kinds of
conspiracy
um and also about malaria prophylaxis
and it was kind of fun to do so you know
how mephoquin ends up affecting your
brain such that you wonder if you're
actually paranoid because of the of the
malaria prophylaxis you're on or if they
really have to get you maybe there's
methiquin in the water that would
explain a lot maybe there's my flipping
in the water yep uh so and and you've
got stuff going on on Twitter now you've
got a Twitter subscription thing going
on encouraging people to go there right
yep I will be delivering some stuff this
week so hang tight if you've subscribed
it's coming oh awesome we have of course
some some stuff that you could buy if
you want Dark Horse merch that's at
darkhorsestore.org The Print Shop who
makes all of our stuff is right here in
the US and it's lovely lovely couple who
who does the stuff we you know we have
the ideas and we work with a wonderful
artist to create the art and you've got
you know epic tabbies and direwolves and
uh visor breakthrough threesome and all
sorts of good stuff there so that's at
darkhorsestore.org we of course have our
book hunter-gatherer's Guide to the 21st
century available everywhere and there's
signed copies available right here in
the islands at darvill's
d-a-r-v-i-l-l-s and you can go online
and find them
find copies there as well if you're not
here on the islands and we have patreons
of course we now have locals as well we
got a lot of stuff going on we're trying
to trying to coalesce but uh at the
moment
um we are a little bit more active on
patreon you've got two weekly two
monthly conversations uh we together do
a private q a at mine right now the uh
the question asking period is open at my
patreon for a monthly private q a which
will happen next week and you can get
access to our Discord server at either
of our patreons where there's
conversations all the time in many media
on all sorts of topics plus book clubs
and happy hours and karaoke and real
life meetups and I don't know which one
you were smiling at but was it the
karaoke uh yes I was that was a fear
that I would be called upon to do
karaoke right now yeah okay
I'm not gonna do that to you
um and the wonderful people on Discord
send us a question
um each week that we start our q and A's
with so we'll be starting we'll be
hearing from Discord uh shortly as soon
as we come back
and again check out our wonderful
sponsors for this week which were iherb
American Heart for gold and MD hearing
aid and reminder we are supported by you
our audience we're on Rumble now
subscribe to the rumble Channel please
and check us out anywhere that you can
find us which is lots of places and
share subscribe like do all of that and
until we see you next time
remember to be good to the ones you love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]